[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département à ces parties a pour le
sommaire versailles en clip gagner les
joueurs de la cité royale se sont
imposés contre paris 15 ce dimanche et
totalise maintenant quatre victoires en
quatre matches plus d'informations dans
ce magazine baseball les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux se sont inclinés
en finale de playoffs de première
division
ils ont été battus dans leur série 3 0
par rouen nous recevrons l'équipe dans
quelques instants sur ce plateau
cyclisme une étape de coupe du monde sur
piste sont organisées à pendant trois
jours à partir de vendredi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
nous avons rencontré l'une des stars de
cette équipe de france françois pervis
sept fois champion du monde
l'actualité à sportive de la semaine
c'est maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du rugby dans le
championnat de division honneur
versailles n'en finit à plus de gagner
les versets y ont engrangé leur
quatrième victoire de la saison en
autant de matches en s'imposant 26 à 9
contre le rc à paris 15e retour sur
cette rencontre un montage de à xavier
jallais les versailles et peuvent
laisser éclater leur joie l'équipe a
encore réalisé une grosse prestation à
domicile ce dimanche 14 octobre contre
paris 15
alors ça ils emportent 26 à 9 avec
quatre essais inscrits et conserve son
invincibilité
on a eu un petit passage un petit peu un
temps faible ans en première période on
a remis les bouchées doubles en début du
début de deuxième mi temps et c'est
dirais pas que c'est sans forcément on a
fui sommes en confiance confiance en nos
forces on est au dessus dans le sens où
on a confiance on a confiance en nos
forces et quand on arrive à jouer
simplement on peut arriver à mettre en
difficulté n'importe qui donc à partir
de là c'est plus facile on est très
contents très satisfait l'engagement
dégâts et de ce qu'ils produisent à
l'entraînement donc on est sur la bonne
la bonne voie avec cette victoire les
joueurs de la cité royale s'envole déjà
au classement l'équipe compte quatre
points d'avancé sur clichy après
seulement quatre journées dans ce
championnat de division honneur
malgré cette place de leader les versets
qui ne veulent pas s'enflammer
l'excès de confiance avancées
importantes dans la vie c'est comme ça
dès qu'on a un peu trop d'excès je pense
que derrière on peut avoir des
déconvenues donc
voilà il faut rester vigilant travail et
bossez continuer parce que bon il ya la
montée en fédérale 3 mais au prix il yal
aventure aussi humaine avec avec les
garçons et encore plein de matches le
premier le plus important c'est de faire
un premier bloc
le premier blade et quatre matches peut
faire que des victoires on s'attendait
pas à prendre autant de points de bonus
bonus offensif france surtout contre des
équipes comme rcp 15 et tendances et
pour nous c'est tout bon pour continuer
à régner sur la division honneur
l'armada offensive versaillaise ira
défier le 11 novembre prochain le
clairement que la brune mis sur son
terrain et pour l'instant les joueurs
peuvent savourer on continue à parler du
rugby-club de versailles vous les avez
peut-être aperçu dans leurs reportages
précédents les joueurs du rcb sont
soutenus à chaque match depuis un an par
un collectif d'ultra versailles est
composé d'une vingtaine de membres
en tout la rencontre ses supporters
installés en haut de la tribune du stade
de porchefontaine n'hésite pas à chanter
danser ou encore à sauter et ils font
beaucoup de bruit regardez
êtes vous tout au long de la saison on
va suivre
suivent le marseillais tel collectif
ultra est en fait tombé à voir tous les
matchs et portez les copains tous les
dimanches que ça soit des missions à
l'extérieur c'est fait
maintenant plus d'un an macrez l'assaut
et tous les moteurs du rugby encore et
toujours avec la poule 2 du championnat
honneur ce dimanche le sky rugby a
concédé une deuxième défaite en deux
matches en s'inclinant à 24 à 20
l'extérieur sur le terrain de vincennes
l'une des meilleures équipes de la poule
après quatre journées le sky pointe à la
cinquième place du championnat honneur à
quatre points du leader l'entente
maisons laffitte saint jean les à poissy
enfin on referme ses résultats rugby
part de la promotion honneur
montigny-le-bretonneux a réussi le bon
coup de cette quatrième journée du
championnat en venant à bout du rugby
ces lois chesnaysiens ce qu'en finale à
19 à 12
une victoire qui permet aux animaux
atteints de rester dans le trio de tête
prochain match le 11 novembre prochain à
domicile contre eux au nez on ouvre
maintenant une page baseball il ya
beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir une partie de l'équipe des
cougars de montigny le bretonneux
finaliste malheureux de première
division les joueurs ont perdu leur
série à 3 0 contre rouen mais cette
année restera quand même la plus belle
de l'histoire du club avec notamment une
qualification en coupe d'europe autour
de cette table on trouve à ma gauche
l'entraîneur rodolphe le meur et un
joueur également jonathan mottet bonsoir
bonsoir
de l'autre côté nous avons la présidente
dé couillard a mis un couteau et le
havre l2 car animaux voie d'eau carmaux
c'est bien ça joueur de l'équipe
également
et tout autour on retrouve franck
lecarpentier le coach assistant et les
joueurs ahmed hague est signalé hors
franck lopez
bonsoir alors comment avez-vous réagi
après cette défaite
est-ce que c'était une défaite attendue
rodolphe non on ne peut pas parler de
défaite attendue série vous disiez
malheureux mais c'est vrai qu'on
s'attend toujours une finale on aime la
gagne et quand on joue c'est parce qu'on
ce qu'on dit souvent une finale ça se
gagne
là on a vraiment fait notre maximum on a
été
on a été le plus haut possible et plutôt
que malheureux on est vraiment heureux
de ce de ceux de ce résultat
en tout cas sur la saison jonathan vous
avez digéré ou passer des fêtes déjà de
longues digère jamais c'est moi j'ai eu
la chance avec mon oncle précédent des
templiers de sénart d'avoir fait
plusieurs finales et surtout contreront
à chaque fois toujours pour la défaite
malheureusement on y voit le positif on
y voit c'était des matches serrés
chapeau à rouyn chapeau sur toi ou wayne
qui finit mvp qui fait un très très gros
match
quand il le faut on voit surtout tout là
toute l'expérience que ça peut nous
allons célébrer le meilleur joueur
meilleur jour annie est ce que vous avez
déjà pris du recul par rapport à cette
défaite
au niveau du staff ou les instants oui
on a pris du recul parce que bon on a
d'abord on est très fier de ce que les
joueurs ont fait parce qu'ils ont
produit des très gros match la victoire
s'est jouée à à une frappe le dernier
match et puis pour une équipe qui est
jeune qui est montée la saison dernière
en division une
on ne peut que les féliciter du chemin
qu'ils ont parcouru les voyelles il y
avait vraiment une classe d'écart entre
rouen et montigny-le-bretonneux où
finalement l'écart était pas sinon
c'était passé nord parce qu'à chaque
match on perd en masse pour des petits
détails une frappe qu'ils ont fait quand
elle essaie de faire et tout d'un coup
ça fait plus mal pour devoir qu'ont été
aussi proche mais de part à cette finale
je rappelle les scores 1 4 1 dans le
premier match 4 à 3 dans le second et 2
à 0 finalement dans le troisième c'est
très peu en verve ces détails c'était de
détails rodolphe vous êtes d'accord
c'est les détails qui ont fait la
différence sur certains moments du jeu
on n'a pas été aussi lucide
que rouen mais c'est l'expérience aussi
comme qui fait de la peine si on prend
de l'expérience trouveront à 14 titres
sur ses apparitions en finale on a eu
affaire à une équipe d'expérience mais
on en a appris beaucoup aussi et on leur
donne rendez vous l'année prochaine je
m'attable vous pensez qu'ils ont été
peut-être un peu surpris par votre
niveau quand même cette équipe de rang
prix non non c'est ce qu' ils ont
l'expérience de aussi jamais prendre les
équipes dos et des jouets respectueux
quand même puis ils sont alors ils sont
à notre place au niveau européen aussi
c'est à dire et à tous il ya des équipes
de tous les niveaux aussi c'est pas non
plus les favoris aujourd'hui c'était les
favoris mais ils ont su aussi nous
prendre comme un vrai compétiteur alors
en saison régulière vous aviez terminé
avec le même nombre de victoires
finalement que oran et pourquoi on
arrive à se sublimer en playoffs alors
que montigny peut-être à peut-être pêché
un peu sur cette finale 7 en termes
d'expérience je pense que c'est en terme
d'expérience aussi puis c'est peut-être
aussi en terme de profondeur du line up
il arrive à frapper du 1er au neuvième
frappeur il arrive à bien frapper
ce qui est clair et ne trahir c'est
l'ordre de passage à la bad des joueurs
et je pense que ça ça me fait quelque
chose qui peut être aussi un peu
déstabilisant pour le pour le lanceur
c'est ça et elise ont plus d'expérience
que nous sur ces compétitions difficile
lanceur qui a affaire à neuf joueurs qui
peuvent frapper à n'importe quel moment
de beaucoup plus réfléchir il n'y a pas
un seul moment où il se dit bon là je
vais je vais me reposer un peu je mets
là-bas le jeu et puis je sais que ça
fera pas non là du 1 au 9
il faut vraiment qu'il reste concentré
et c'est très très dur à faire vous avez
sentiment rodolphe quand même d'avoir
marqué quand même l'histoire du club
oui avec cette finale moi et tout à fait
c'est vraiment c'est ce projet dans ce
sens aussi tout autre énorme je pense
que c'est vraiment comme disait à nice
et une deuxième année en d1 c'est une
remontée deuxième année on arrive à
faire affaire être finalistes c'est
vraiment que c'est très rare enfin je ne
sais pas si ça s'est déjà fait par les
années précédentes qu'une équipe arrive
en deux ans deux ans à être les deux
finalistes
et oui on a marqué et aujourd'hui on
fait partie du duo niveau en tout cas du
top top 3 des équipes en france
johnatan qu'est ce qui a fait finalement
là la force de l'équipe tout au long de
la saison nous c'est soit que c'était la
grippe ya un vrai goût on peut le dire
une famille puisque pour le coup on le
dit beaucoup dans le sport mais là
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça juste en
sait on sait qu'on sera toujours là les
uns pour les autres que ce soit des
moments difficiles parce que faut pas
l'oublier avant la pause on a eu comme
tout couple comme toute famille des
embrouilles on a eu des moments
difficiles on se voyait pas à cette
place aujourd'hui et le fait d'avoir
tout de suite après la pause rattaquer
les demies l'écart dans la manière dont
on l'a fait ces énoncés
c'est très soudée ya voyelles vous êtes
d'accord oui complètement d'accord parce
que surtout dans l'équipe en a de
différentes nationalités on a deux des
gens qui se connaissaient moi je connais
les de cette équipe cette année et de
coulommiers nouveau je vais je suis
brésilien
mais avant de jouer à saint lô en
normandie une couche est arrivé cette
année en cette équipe et directe dû
m'accrocher avec les gens parce que
c'est vraiment une famille
les étrangers également ont été très
bien intégré un îlot rappelait justement
précédemment gabrielle soucisse à la
force de montigny de d'intégrer
facilement les joueurs étrangers tout à
fait puisé les joueurs étrangers sont
quand même une force pour le club parce
qu'ils apportent quand même notre regard
que sur le baseball sont des gens qui
parfois ont joué dans des équipes
américaines ont joué à un haut niveau
il apporte quelque chose il apporte
quelque chose alors non seulement l
équipement l'ensemble du club aussi on
ailleurs franck qui est avec nous a
justement sur ce plateau c'est qu'elle a
été élue meilleur lanceur cessa de la
saison c'est ce que vise à nice et
récurrents font énormément de choses
aujourd'hui avec son expérience aux
états unis et pour les lanceurs aussi
qui sont plus jeunes qui ont
l'expérience c'est c'est un atout majeur
aujourd'hui tout cas cette année ça a
été un atout majeur
ça a été un vrai plus pour l'équipe
johnatan de l'avoir beaucoup c'est
vivien et met tout de suite le rythme et
puis il ay la hausse il a envie de
partager son expérience
après je voulais revenir sur tout son
effectif c'est qu'on a la chance que ce
soir rodolphe annie ou franck
tous les autres noms du club ils font
d'abord un tri en fait ils expliquent
déjà les valeurs du club
donc c'est à dire en sortant de toute
façon ensemble c'est là déjà une
sélection qui est fait à la base ce
qu'ils font je ne sais pas la manière
dont ça se fait mais en fait on sait
qu'on va s'entendre avec les garder leur
secret l'un pour pas donné les astuces
aux deux clubs mais on sait qu'on va
s'entendre tout de suite avec le
coéquipier même si c'est pas de la même
nationalité est de la même région du
même bien l'expérience sont plus c'est
vrai que c'est important pour nous
d'avoir un groupe un vrai groupe parce
que sur vous avez des gens qui viennent
les dimanches on est des amateurs
et si l'on n'arrive pas vraiment à créer
cette cohésion d'une équipe
les résultats ce sont 100 ressentent
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a
malgré certains certains doutes on a
réussi à vraiment à re motiver et puis à
garder cette cohésion qui nous a emmené
en finale quelle sera la suite du coup
pour cette équipe senior découvrir de
petits bretons ne m'a déjà est-ce que
vous restez au club rodolphe ah bah je
sais pas on verra si le club me donner
encore son sa confiance oui je resterai
avec plaisir c'est vrai qu'il ya une
coupe d'europe quand même on a gagné on
a gagné sept places en coupe d'europe et
c'est un gros challenge c'est quelque
chose d'énorme pour le club de coupe
d'europe qui se disputera sur une
semaine c'est sa lettre c'est en
décembre que sera validé le lieu et la
date
et c'est vrai que là tout le travail va
être fait là dessus il ya un gros
travail qui va être fait par franck
d'autres membres du club pour le
recrutement puisque c'est vrai comme on
en parlait tout à l'heure on avait
quelques faiblesses
il va falloir qu'on se renforce pour
être au niveau de musique et cambron
pour avoir iv aussi avoir neuf frappeurs
qui peut faire le la différence il va
falloir qu'on recrute
et puis il va falloir surtout
financièrement trouver de l'argent
voilà c'est aussi le nerf de la guerre
il va falloir qu'on trouve puisque ça
coûte cher aux coupes d'europe l'année
prochaine
c'est le titre nous visaient à ni
évidemment évidemment bien sûr je pense
qu'on peut pas être président c'est
maintenant on peut pas être président de
club ou même joueur d'un club on se
satisfait en se satisfaisant de quelque
chose de passable non là ils ont fait
bien cette année même très bien donc
l'année prochaine il faut qu'ils sont
exceptionnels c'est noté en tout cas
merci à vous d'être passé au grand
plateau aujourd'hui encore bravo pour
cette saison si les saint quentinois
peuvent être fiers de bouffe on
continuera évidemment à vous suivre sur
les temps en france et en coupe d'europe
on disait précédemment
on continue à ce magazine par deux la
course à pied plaisir fêté ce samedi la
4e édition de ça au run and bike
pour l'occasion les organisateurs
avaient concocté un tracé de 15 km un
autre de 8 km entre le parc du château
de plaisir et le bois de la crâne le
concept est simple les participants
répartis en binômes de vettel ternes et
course à pied et vélo sur le parcours et
pour emporter la victoire chaque duo
collègues amis en fout famille avait sa
propre technique
les sportifs ont dévoilé leur stratégie
au micro de notre journaliste marc il n
'ya piché je commence par le vélo pour
supporter puisse commencer un peu plus
en forme et après du coup comme je
reçois un traîneau si je prendrait le
relais
donc à ce qu'on pense qu'on l'aura bien
accéléré en gros tous les tous les 4 500
mètres environ va changer c'est vraiment
en mode un peu fractionné donc faire
changer souvent ce qui est dur c'est
monsieur les côtes c'est ça le vélo est
le plus facile des kilomètres voilà
toutes les trois minutes on change donc
ça on l'a déjà testé une fois donc ça
devrait aller
on n'a pas encore décidé qui commençait
parcourir qui commençait par le vélo
donc on va improviser
il nous reste un peu de temps pour
décidément course à pied encore la 9e
édition du trail des sept hameaux était
organisée ce dimanche matin dès 9 heures
au départ de magny les hameaux
au programme cette année un trail de 18
km des courses pour les plus jeunes et
de la marche nordique
la course phare était un trail de 32 km
en pleine nature avec des montées des
descentes en forêt la compétition a
rassemblé encore cette année plus de
1200 coureurs venus des quatre coins de
l'île de france comment expliquer ce
succès la réponse avec l'un des
organisateurs de la course jérôme arru
d'elle c'est à la mode un tout le monde
connaît le succès de l'ultra trail du
mont blanc de ces grandes courses
d'ultra trail et je pense que c'est les
gens sont apprécié les courses nature ça
leur donne un petit peu l'impression
d'être auront en contact à que nature en
harmonie et que nature dont je pense que
ouais c'est un petit peu un retour aux
sources pour les urbains que nous sommes
une deuxième édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine et
organisateurs envisagent de mettre en
place quelques surprises pour fêter
cette décennie un mot de football à
présent jouer ce week-end le 5e tour de
la coupe de france les principaux
résultats du département
ça passe pour versailles qui s'impose 3
1 sur le terrain de saint germain sentry
poissy sera également présent au 6e tour
les pisciacais ont dominé livry gargan 3
2 après prolongation c'est terminé pour
wii qui s'incline aux tirs au but contre
ivry même scénario pour les mureaux sur
le terrain de saint maur epône se fait
sortir par bobigny 3 0 et conflans perd
contre fleury mérogis 2 à 1
en basket coup d'arrêt pour trappe
invaincu jusqu'à cette quatrième journée
dans le championnat de nationale 3 les
trappistes se sont inclinés cents à 84
sur le terrain de barjouville une
défaite sans conséquence sur le
classement les saint quentinois reste
premier avec 7 points engrangés du
handball à présent dans le championnat
de nationale 3 à plaisir est en panne
d'efficacité en ce moment les plaisirs
oies se sont inclinés à 27 à 23 à
l'extérieur contre mulhouse lors de la
4e journée
au classement en plaisir plongée se
retrouve à l'avant dernière place avec
seulement 6 points engrangés depuis le
début du championnat du handball mais
cette fois ci à féminin dans le
championnat de nationale 2 montigny le
bretonneux a réalisé une belle opération
ce dimanche en s'imposant contre
colombelles à l'extérieur le score 29 à
24 une victoire qui permet aux inimitiés
de grappiller des places au classement
pour se retrouver en huitièmes un
dernier mot de rugby et dans ce magazine
avant de passer à notre page agenda le
président de la ffr à bernard laporte a
commencé le 15 septembre dernier
quatorze mesures visant à renforcer la
sécurité de la pratique de ce sport avec
notamment la règle du passage en force
les explications avec nicolas d'ambri
défendre en touchant son adversaire et
lui laisser deux secondes pour faire une
passe c'est la nouvelle règle mise en
place dans les écoles de rugby et
notamment ici au rugby-club de
versailles une disposition en oeuvre
depuis quatre ans en ile-de-france pour
favoriser un style de jeu et sécuriser
les joueurs le but c'est d'inciter par
la règle à faire évoluer le jeu donc
c'est du rugby à toucher donc avec
continuité du jeu touché deux secondes
touché avec ballons donnés au contact
aujourd'hui s'est repris et par la
fédération française au niveau des
écoles de rugby et aujourd'hui ce qui se
rajoutent ont plus effectivement c'est
le passage en force qui pour des raisons
sécuritaires quand un défenseur est
arrêté ça peut être un peu plus
dangereux donc ça c'est une donnée
supplémentaire qui sécurise l'ensemble
du jeu de rugby
recherchez les espaces s'en allait
obligatoirement au contact
l'enseignement donné par les éducateurs
à versailles tout en préparant aux
plaquages les petits rugbyman dès le
plus jeune âge avec cette volonté
d'éviter les chocs violents
ce jeu de mouvement ça a un intérêt dans
le sens où le porteur de balle va
chercher à éviter les défenseurs à
avancer dans les intervalles et donc à
ne pas rentrer dans le mur comme on peut
voir sur certaines vidéos de pro on
apprend sur le plaquage par exemple à
bien passé sa tête sur le côté avec la
tête calée sur la fesse qui est molle
pour ne pas justement se faire mal donc
en fait on apprend plusieurs mouvements
qu'une met en sécurité les enfants
à versailles les moins de 8 ans joue à
l'épervier adapté au rugby le but ne pas
se faire attraper en traversant le
terrain c'est quand même un jeu
quelconque effet pour le contournement
donc c'est assez intéressant dans le
sens où nous nous ce qu'on recherche
c'est à éviter l'adversaire alors après
il ya ce qu'il y à 7,2 selon plaquages
mais qui est quand même importante dans
le rugby parce qu'on fait quand même un
sport qui en a besoin
un sport qui attire toujours autant les
petits versailles et l'école de rugby
compte près de 250 licenciés chaque
saison sur ces dernières années
[Musique]
cyclisme sur piste à présent la première
coupe du monde au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est programmée
ce vendredi samedi et dimanche au total
52 pays seront représentés ses 366
athlètes participeront à ce rendez vous
parmi eux ali ni monte à françois pervis
sept fois champion du monde il défendra
évidemment les couleurs de la france et
compte remporter des médailles nous
l'avons rencontré une étape de coupe du
monde sera organisée ici au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
19 20 et 21 octobre à mes côtés françois
pervis multiple champion du monde
françois comment vous l'appréhendez
cette compétition on l'apprend tu bien
on est à domicile donc forcément ça
donne beaucoup plus engouement
et on avait moite d'en découdre parce
qu'à domicile on n'a vraiment pas
souvent l'occasion d'y courir
donc là on a une très très belle
occasion donc on est vraiment sûr motivé
on attend le public avec son impatience
en masse et pour pouvoir vivre tout
simplement des démos des beaux moments
de sport vous avez gagné deux titres de
champion du monde ici en 2015
est ce que vous êtes dans la même
optique rafler le maximum de titres sur
la compétition effectivement oui en 2015
a été double deux fois champion du monde
ici donc c'était vraiment des moments
inoubliables pour moi en tant que
qu'athlète là pour cette manche de coupe
du monde forcément on attend de nous
beaucoup quand on est champion du monde
plusieurs fois même avec les collègues
l'équipe de france est très attendue
surtout à domicile donc on espère être à
la hauteur on pense qu'on va l'être on
n'a pas de souci particulier
à avoir donc on attend simplement d'être
sur le départ de la ligne de départ et
puis de ya les puits de foncer pour
aller décrocher des podiums pour vous
c'est un plus vraiment d'être à domicile
vous pensez que le public peut encore
plus vous pousser assez sur le public
qu'ont à domicile
il est vraiment on a des ailes qui nous
pousse notamment moi je me suis rendu
compte en 2015
physiquement j'étais n'était pas
vraiment au top et pourtant le public
m'a vraiment aidé ça m'a aidé à gagner
deux titres de champion du monde
ce qu'on vous dit qu'ils assimilent
personne qui vous crie dessus je peux
vous dire que ça fait vraiment la
différence et tu te sens j'étais en
transe j'étais transcendé
je sentais plus mes gens mais
mentalement ça donne un coup de boost
incroyable et j'ai hâte de pouvoir
revivre ça dans quelques semaines
justement physiquement comment vous vous
sentez en ce moment en ce moment là je
suis un petit peu fatiguée parce que je
viens de finir un gros bloc
d'entraînement de quatre semaines oui
beaucoup de quantité donc forcément ça
ça fatigue
là les trois semaines qui me reste je
vais les optimiser je m'entraîne pas
beaucoup mais je pour autres la
fraîcheur afin d'être percutant le jour
de la course et pour aussi emmagasinée
et tolérer les quatre semaines que je
viens de faire pour les assimiler
voilà donc d'ici là d'ici la course je
fais du très light et en espérant être
le plus percutant possible pour cette
manche de coupe du monde
une étape de coupe du monde justement
c'est quoi dans un calendrier finalement
c'est une grosse compétition une
compétition intermédiaire c'est quoi
selon vous ça reste une compétition
intermédiaire mais là maintenant qu'on
rentre dans la sélection pour les jeux
olympiques il faut pas se louper
toutes les compétitions internationales
de ce niveau là vont être
votre bénéfique
pour l'équipe de france si marc des
beaux points après ça peut être le cas
inverse mais on est là pour marquer des
points il faut pas se louper puisque
dans deux ans il va falloir avoir assez
de points pour avoir tous les quotas au
niveau de déchets olympique donc c'est
très important
on a le droit à quelques erreurs
puisqu'il ya en tout 16 rendez vous
d'ici les jeux olympiques et je crois
qu'ils prennent les six meilleurs se dit
pas de bêtise mais c'est quand même
important d'être de gagner ou de garder
plutôt notre 32 meilleures mondiales
cette sélection de vitesse il y aura des
bauges et bien sûr il y aura sébastien
vigion michael d'almeida
c'est une équipe quand même très forte
sur papier oui c'est une équipe sur
papier à quelque chose près on a fait
une médaille de 3e au championnat du
monde cette année
on a aussi fait vice championne d'europe
cet été
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils se sait ici on
espère vraiment
un podium un beau podium ça va être dur
compliqué puisqu'il y aura les champions
du monde en titre et mais bon pourquoi
pas les battre
on se donne en donnera les moyens en
tout cas un petit mot également sur les
féminines mathilde gros sandie clair est
ce qu'on pensait qu'elles peuvent
ramener également des médailles
ah oui oui apple veut ramener des
médailles par équipes ça reste toujours
un petit peu un petit peu dur mais on a
des vies duels on a vu matt hill de gros
est championne d'europe cet été
vraiment un très beau titre de champion
d'europe en kering donc ici elle va être
à domicile aussi il va falloir qu
etienne la pression
ce sera aussi tout nouveau pour elle
mais en tout cas où on peut lui faire
confiance pour nous ramener des belles
médailles
vous avez la trentaine passée 1 il faut
pas se le cacher vous êtes plus vers la
fin que vers le début
est ce que vous apportez également votre
expérience à ce groupe si jeune à des
sébastien vigier qui ont vingt deux ans
mathilde de gros qui à 19 ans est ce que
vous a apporté cette expérience
nécessaire au cyclisme de haut niveau
oui je suis là pour ça
c'est surtout pour ça aussi que je suis
encore là en compétition il me pose pas
mal de questions un peu moins maintenant
parce qu'il commence à avoir leur propre
leur propre expérience mais à
l'entraînement ou ou dans la vie de tous
les jours
quand on les voit un petit peu dans le
dur parce qu'il n'ya pas aussi que la la
la la vie de sportif qui compte donc
j'essaie simplement de les aiguiller de
de savoir les tempérer quand il faut et
puis de les motiver qu'on s'a reese un
petit coup de mou parce qu'on reste
humain avant tout et on n'est pas des
machines et donc parfois on a des hauts
et des bas et quand il ya débat il faut
savoir être là aussi pour les soutenir
donc
s'ils me demandent mon aide je suis là
sans problème un dernier mot pour le
public saint quentinois qui viendra vous
voir vous supporter on espère qu'il sera
là en nombre eux on compte vraiment sur
lui parce que là il va y avoir vraiment
du spectacle
comme l'a dit le président seulement
pour 15 euros vous pouvez passer une
journée à voir du vrai spectacle ici les
meilleurs mondiaux
ça reste du cyclisme sur piste donc
c'est très spectaculaire on n'a pas le
temps de s'ennuyer
il va y avoir du sprint de l'endurance
qu'il faut si vous connaissez pas venez
venez simplement par curiosité
et puis vous verrez vous n'allez pas
vraiment pas le regretter
et il ya beaucoup d'adrénaline ya des
chutes c'est vrai ça se joue au
millimètre près ya la photo finish
donc c c'est même stressant pour public
et c'est ça que ça fait vibrer le
cyclisme sur piste fait vibrer donne des
frissons et des émotions donc il faut
vraiment pas louper ça merci beaucoup
françois pervis l'étape de coupe du
monde ici au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce sera le 19
20 et 21 octobre prochains
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]